das ist eine echte bombe die da
eigentlich bereits ende januar geplatzt
ist aber niemand hat das mitbekommen
einen tag vor der amtseinführung von joe
biden als präsident der vereinigten
staaten am 19 januar ist ramms mann an
der spitze der nasa jim briten stein
zurückgetreten und mit ihm ist ein
ehrgeiziger plan in weite ferne gerückt
die mondlandung 2024 warum das so ist
und wieso das bisher noch niemand so
richtig mitbekommen hat dass jetzt
inklusive aller hintergründe in
kriegszeiten future bis dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und vergesst nicht
im podcast für unterwegs zu abonnieren
hierunter me oder in der video
beschreibung oder im ersten angeboten
kommentare sind die links erst im
letzten video hatten wir über die
geplante mondlandung berichtet aber wenn
man eins und eins zusammenzählt ist die
mehr als fraglich denn an allen ecken
und enden hakt es und ja jetzt oder
besser bereits ende januar hat der mann
die nasa verlassen der das projekt
artemis für donald trump durch boxen
sollte nasa administrator jim bottoms
sein und selbst sein stellvertreter
übernahmen nicht die kommissarische
leitung wie sonst üblich sondern ein
mann aus der zweiten reihe ist die ju
schick übernimmt vorübergehend die
leitung das signal ist deutlich auch die
nasa bricht mit der tram schon
vergangenheit jim brittens sein war ein
äußerst umstrittener nasa-direktor er
war klima skeptiker bevor er zur nasa
kam und stieß deshalb und weil er der
erste nasa-direktor ohne
naturwissenschaftliches studium war auf
ablehnung doch für donald trump kämpfte
er sein ehrgeiziges artemis programm
durch nach knapp 50 jahren sollten
wieder amerikanische astronauten auf dem
mond landen und zum ersten mal sollte
eine frau den fuß als erste auf einen
anderen himmelskörper setzen artemis ist
der name der mondgöttin und
zwillingsschwester napoleons aus der
griechischen mythologie eine anlehnung
also an die apollo-missionen die usa
sehen den bemannten flug zum mond auch
als einen test für eine bemannte
mars-mission angedacht ist diese für die
2030er jahre doch der zeitplan ist
bereits jetzt dramatisch aus den fugen
geraten
das space launch system sls wird einfach
nicht fertig und auch die orion kapsel
hat bei ihrem test
im letzten jahr die internationale
raumstation iss verfehlt während spacex
mit der korrekten und der felge rakete
quasi den regulären flugbetrieb zu heiß
es aufgenommen hat kommt die nasa selbst
nicht aus den puschen
erst 2009 10 hatte wird es sein das sls
vorgestellt eine riesige rakete und laut
bündnis dann ein zitat wichtiger
meilenstein und ein beweis für das
amerikanische unternehmertum und den
erfindergeist mit mehr als 1.000 einer
großen und kleinen unternehmen in 44
staaten die zur konstruktion und montage
beitragen wird die sls rakete amerika
befähigen das ziel des artemis programms
zu erreichen
die erste frau und den nächsten mann bis
2024 auf dem mond zu landen
den bemannten erst flug zum mond steht
quasi nichts mehr im wege
so hieß es damals 2020 sollte der
orangefarbene gigant das erste mal
getestet werden und 2021 soll die akte
an orion raumschiff um den mond
transportieren allerdings unbemannt ein
bemannter staat sollte 2022 folgen für
das jahr 2024 war dann der große kuh der
nasa geplant mehr als 51 jahre nach der
letzten mondlandung sollte dann also auf
eine frau teil der besatzung seien 65
meter hoch und damit so groß oder so
hoch wie ein 20 stöckiges gebäude ist
die super g des space launch system
doch nicht nur das ist ein rekord auch
ihre leistung übertrumpft alles nach
offiziellen nasa-angaben erreicht sie
eine rekord überschallgeschwindigkeit
vom 823 also 23 facher
schallgeschwindigkeit umgerechnet sind
das 28 1400 kilometer pro stunde
diese geschwindigkeit soll sie erreichen
bis sie dann von der orion mannschafts
kapsel getrennt wird doch all die
ehrgeizigen ziele sind nicht erreicht
worden die rakete wird einfach nicht
einsatzbereit gerade erst am 16 januar
musste der achtminütige testlauf der
ersten stufe der ersten sms rakete die
starten soll
nach 67 sekunden wegen eines
hydraulikproblems abgebrochen werden
spricht der erste staat der sls der ja
eigentlich schon 2020 stattfinden sollte
der wird wahrscheinlich nicht mal 2021
stattfinden können und dazu muss man
festhalten dass die falken heavy bereits
seit geraumer zeit startklar ist und
zudem für die reise zum mond geeignet
und das seid weiter
18 das ganze projekt wurde vor allem von
der us regierung um präsident donald
trump nach vorne getrieben und die
kosten laufen immer weiter aus dem ruder
und sie werden inzwischen begrenzt und
das ist das todesurteil für die mission
das budget für den länder die neue
mondfähre das human landing system hs
wurde von 3,3 milliarden dollar auf ein
viertel gekürzt für das finanzjahr 2021
aber das scheint tatsächlich eine
unaufhaltbare verzögerung zu sein denn
wer weiß auf 2022 diese mittel
bereitgestellt werden währenddessen
testet und testet space extra starship
eine noch stärkere täter als die falcon
heavy und auch stärker als die sls am
besten kann man das mit den fracht
gewicht vergleichen
dass die verschiedenen raketen in den
leo den low earth orbit also den unteren
erdorbit bringen können also zur ssd
lediglich vier kilometer über unseren
köpfen um die erde kreist die apollo
rakete die saturn 5 konnte 140 tonnen
dorthin bringen
die falcon heavy lediglich 30 tonnen
aber das space launch system auch nur 95
tonnen dreimal so viel wie defekten
heavy aber deutlich weniger als die
saturn 5 allerdings ganz da stimmt dort
156 tonnen bringt wenn es also mal
startet ist es die stärkste je gebaute
rakete und beim starship ist geplant die
rakete im weltraum wieder zu bedanken so
dass sie ähnliche tonnagen sogar bis zum
mond bringen könnte oder eben direkt zum
master auch wenn spacex testet und
testet auch hier funktioniert es nicht
so richtig zum zweiten mal gab es zwar
keine bruchlandung und auch einen mast
starship steckt noch in den
kinderschuhen allerdings wurde es auch
als mögliche landeeinheit für artemis
ausgewählt und im moment entwickelt
basics aufzüge um nach der landung von
der hohen rakete auf den mond zu kommen
denn mit einer leiter wie bei dem apollo
11 igel länder da wird das kaum gelingen
aber bei spex wird die landeeinheit mit
der rakete zusammen fertig gestellt sie
ist nämlich eine landeeinheit da werden
dann nicht zusätzlich 3,3 milliarden
dollar für die entwicklung benötigt und
wenn space extra seinen starship einmal
fertig hat dann könnte es sein dass es
immer noch nicht flugbereit ist und
zudem kostet ein starship satz
was sich nur den bruchteil eines sls
starts bei der sls ist man wieder bei
rund einer milliarde dollar gelandet
auch letztlich ein todesurteil für einen
regelmäßigen flugbetrieb zum mond
während ein starship staat lediglich 100
millionen dollar kosten wird und wir
sehen ja bei den fetten staat was für
einen unterschied solche billig starts
mit wiederverwendbaren raketen ausmachen
26 ist in der lage ständig eigenes
zahling satelliten in den weltraum zu
schicken und somit diesen satelliten
internet die eigene gelddruckmaschine
aufzubauen schon jetzt funktioniert sie
der beta test hat bereits begonnen wenn
es so weitergeht und das sollte man
bedenken dann ist ihnen masken mix
basics bald in der lage die nasa
komplett in den schatten zu stellen und
eine eigene mond beziehungsweise den
mond wird er wahrscheinlich auslassen
eine eigene maß station aufzubauen nur
bei einem können wir uns wahrscheinlich
sehr sicher sein
weder in den mast basics noch die nasa
werden es bis 2024 schaffen können
ein mensch den fuß auf einen fremden
himmelskörper setzen zu lassen
der drops ist mit allerhöchster
wahrscheinlichkeit zwischen gelutscht
und nach der pandemie wird den
amerikanern das geld auch nicht so
gerade locker sitzen da dürfte jeder
cent umgedreht werden und vielleicht
rollt man sich dann auch wenn spacex
bereits alles am start hat und
beauftragte das unternehmen schlichtweg
mit der mondlandung wie es ja jetzt auch
schon bei der kur decken funktioniert
werden die orion-kapsel es nicht zur iss
geschafft hat flix basics quasi einen
liniendienst eine mondlandung 2024
können wir uns also abschminken
doch es bleibt und wird spannend hier
geht es weiter mit einer atemberaubenden
idee ganze städte im weltraum und zwar
zwischen mars und jupiter also anklicken
an staunt und abonnieren
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran